that oracle magnus is from turkey
let's play something solid
trying to get some sort of
sinus variation
i don't know exactly what this um
this line with a6 and g6 is called
i think with just g6 and not a6 it's
called dismissal variation but
um okay so
is there a reason why i can't go here
i guess this makes sense in conjunction
with gtx e5
i mean usually bishop g5 doesn't
doesn't really do a whole lot or
sometimes
it makes sense to provoke the knight to
e7 because it very often would rather go
to f6
but this what he's doing now i don't it
just looks like he lost time h6 is
useful for me
um i guess it depends where he puts his
position
like bishop h4 does not okay it looks
looks a bit
artificial i he'll probably play bishop
b3
and i think i can go f5
the only thing downside of f5 would be
efg f
knight h4 that i can castle there and
see why that's an issue
[Music]
so it looks like i i sort of got a dream
dream version of it all
yeah i would suspect he's going to go
knight h4
or castle and if and he can play f4
because knight 65 doesn't work
let's check on d5
i think i should castle
queen h5 doesn't worry me f4
this looks good looks like the right way
to play
i don't really want him to take so i'll
probably play e4 myself
actually it's kind of annoying that my
bishop on d7
is taking a square of my where my knight
would like to go and i would
ideally love to be on f6
and g3 looks logical
um so this is a bit of a question
i can actually like the idea of putting
the bishop on e8
on f7 and putting pressure on d5 my d7
f6 is coming as well
yeah um
okay let's play 97. he'll take it he'll
get a check on d4
i think and then i can go knight f6
he's kind of he's not fully developed
the way that he wants to i think i can
play knight to six there's no
in g4 fg bishop e4
i don't think that worries me
i'm not sure
yeah i don't think that worries me
attribution before i have c5 and
and i can take back okay c4
it's kind of asking for c5 now i don't
know what he wants to do as well by
queen c3
and then after b5 i'll have to i'll have
to make some strange moves
but it actually i mean i'd rather break
up his center i don't see how i'm going
to do that c6 doesn't appeal to me so
let's go for c5 i think he'll play queen
c3
because if he takes i i can i take with
the pawn looks
looks decent
if you could get his b1 knight to e3
then my position would be kind of kind
of terrible
but that takes a very long time
does this concern me if i play
d5 i also have rook b8
i don't think he wants to take yet and
because uh taking on b2 will will be
really huge in that game
this looks fine yeah i mean he could
just play b3 of course
but i guess this is a good inclusion
would be it in d3 for me
and then i'll probably play d5
i guess he um yeah i was wondering about
this can't i take
what's the what's the problem with
taking
94 rook c2 knight
d6 i mean it doesn't doesn't seem like
it's likely to work
i also have like c5 it's sort of an
attractive move
rook b2 i just don't see it
maybe bishop before fe4 94 is what he's
hoping for i i have queen b6 there
yeah i'm not seeing his attack maybe he
just wants to play like bishop b3
that actually might be his idea
i can play c5 actually i'm not liking
that too much
maybe i should just play d5 here
d5 has queen e5
okay i i prefer that too ricky two
bishop v3 just suddenly doesn't seem
very appealing
i mean queen if i i still okay this
actually makes me
a little bit happier that he chose to
take
it just seems like
[Music]
it frees my my bishop more freeze my
pieces
yeah now
um seven and then he'll queenie five
me five i mean i'm ready to lose the f5
palm now
just to
yeah i didn't want to allow him to take
him knight at five and win a pawn man
game
so he'll take on a5 he wins upon but i
still have this a really
big center and his queen is also
i don't think it's trapped but it's
forced to go to some strange squares
yeah hp6 queen e5 bishop g4 actually
wins in exchange but i don't know if i
want that i'd rather
go here of course into h3 and then d4
it starts to look really nice yeah i can
also give him a check first but
then e3 d4 looks pretty good
it doesn't threaten anything but if i
get my pawn to d3 it's just
it's just a disaster for him that will
basically be the end of the game
so yeah f5 sort of what i was thinking
bishop h5 looks good g4 bishop g4
if rook d2 i mean i can play e3 which
looks winning
so i know maybe he'll play g4 tag and
queen g3 but that that doesn't seem to
help him very much
um my d5 i can just take on d1
yeah i think this is the end of the game
i don't know where it went
wrong for him exactly
queen effect it seemed like he was doing
everything right and then probably
taking over on that five was just too
greedy
so take on d1
take on f6
d3 queen g4 king h8 doesn't worry me
my pawns are really strong i can
play e3 tag e2
let's go for them
two and one
okay
all right that was a fun game